[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
obviously senior enum would be this
crowd is delighted to see you here
desire I'm pleased to be here to honor
all foreign language films and
particularly the five nominated by the
Academy
no matter and what tongue the dialogue
is spoken all film speak common language
each is a journey that takes us from my
theater seats to another place and
another time this year's nominees took
us on journeys Switzerland Poland
Hungary Japan and Italy and not once you
lose a luggage the nominees are the boat
is full a limbo film Ag production from
Switzerland a Polish declaration fulfill
unit X production for Poland an economy
is in a feast Oh am a film objective
studio monthly dunya production from
hunger
Tamura production from japan and the
final film is three brothers on ether
film Rome Gumo Parrish production from
Italy the winner is Hungary for Mephisto
[Applause]
[Music]
it is and gentlemen thank you very much
for this marvelous things and thank for
mr. Claus Maria Brandauer Austrian dr.
Klaus don't miss me I am so allowed here
and many thanks to the marvelous
cinematographer Hungarian
cinematographer mr. colt ie and for the
screenplay
mr. Dubey and miss Sokka and Katara's
eater and mr. Mertz producer and mr. ma
Fredonia producer and and mr. ovary and
my family and and miss kerime Randhawa
and miss very durable thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
later at the Governor's Ball they plan
to announce their engagement
you